on va écouter madame mais quelques
secondes qui a été réélu qui est chef du
son de son parti vert simplement le
féliciter pour avoir été réélu je peux
aussi vous dire que la banque le stade
la pêche appelé justin trudeau gelé
appelé pour le féliciter pour former le
prochain gouvernement et lui demander
quand est-ce que nous pouvons avoir la
peur je ne rencontre sur la conférence
du climat qui se tiendra le mois
prochain
alors ce n'est pas bien sûr mon discours
il ya des choses que je vais devoir dire
très bientôt mais tout d'abord je veux
vous présenter ma faim je ne suis pas je
suis très chanceuse parce
qu'actuellement tout tout mais mais mais
mais bien sûr mais comme étant mais
comme étant les méchants du jeu j'aime
travailler pour vous j'ai eu de
magnifiques bénévoles mais ça ne fait
pas partie de bien sûr de mon discours
alors bien sûr j'ai des gens qui sont
avec moi halter blacks
je vais les années ici sur le sur las le
podium ensuite nous aurons de la musique
et aussi de sa finale en plein de scènes
de chilliwack qui va jouer la chanson
que je me suis chanter à moi même tous
les 60 et 17 longs jours de la campagne
nous allons reprendre ce pays